this video is brought to you by wren
what's up guys michael here to tackle
the fabulous chaos of rick and morty
season 5 premiere
mort dinner rick andre a lot happens
particularly for an episode that largely
takes place inside the family home we
meet rick's best nemesis yet a
hypersexual sea lord
i'm going to make the land what who
happens to control the police police
take this piece of [ __ ] to jail ugh i
told uh
i told you he's an ice-cold dick killer
also
jerry says the most chilling words any
child could ever hear
we've been watching pornography together
i might never come back
and morty once again tries to shoot his
14 year old shot
i just want to say that you're really
great i know the timing never really
worked out with us but you're really
great and i wish i got to know you
better but the most
interesting part for us was the
development of the hoovy verse
a world behind a magical narnia door
where time
moves fast what starts innocently enough
with rick recruiting morty to use the
portal to
age some wine so time moves faster in
there
it's like a narnia thing i'm not a
beaver who believes in jesus christ
morty
but yeah it's pretty much a narnia thing
butterfly effects into a high-tech
civilization
founded on a collective hatred for your
favorite high school neurotic
more than just a fun subplot this
storyline can teach us a lot about how
civilizations develop
with the help of a couple dead
philosophers so join us as we explore
whether aggression and war are at the
heart of all human societies
and don't worry it should be totally fun
let's get into this wisecrack quick take
on rick and morty season 5 episode 1
how violence builds society and as
always spoilers ahead
but before we get into it i want to give
a shout out to this video sponsor
ren now i don't know about you guys but
the constant bad news about climate
change
sucks and the worst part is i feel like
there's nothing i can do about it and
this is where ren comes in rent is a
website that helps you calculate your
carbon footprint
and then shows you how you can offset
your footprint by funding projects that
do things like plant trees
and protect rainforests rather than just
feeling bad about the climate crisis
with ren
you can actually do something about it
all without having to spend all day
outside getting sweaty and dirty while
planting trees
all you have to do is answer a few
questions about your lifestyle
and wren will calculate your carbon
footprint and help you reduce it
now as much as i've tried no one can
reduce their carbon footprint to zero
but you can offset what you have left
after reducing it on your own
because you're already trying to reduce
your carbon footprint on your own
right once you sign up to make a monthly
contribution that will be used to offset
your carbon footprint
you'll receive monthly updates from the
projects you support they'll actually
send you pictures of trees that you
planted
so you can see what your money was spent
on and i mean who doesn't want pictures
of beautiful
trees showing up in their inbox
seriously slide into my dms trees we all
know it's going to take a lot of work to
slow down the climate crisis
so why not start today we've partnered
with wren to protect
five extra acres of rainforest for the
first 100 people who sign up
using our referral link so go to
www.wren.com
join wisecrack to join us in saving the
rainforest and fighting the climate
crisis
that's wren.co join slash wisecrack
and now back to the show now when we
first meet the gentle jovial hoovy
he and his very pregnant wife are living
on a simple idyllic farmstead surrounded
by fields of flowers there's no
signs of technology and definitely no
weapons the vibes as the kids would say
are mellow and hoovy graciously helps
morty carry some aged
wine back through the portal of course
when time doesn't so much
tick by as a gallop things are bound to
change
fast hoovey returns to a much darker
world to find his wife now a
significantly less charming skeleton and
his creepy now-born son
who stabs him in vengeance for being a
deadbeat dad in his dying words hoovey
establishes morty as the foundational
cause for his family's woes was it
my fault who's them who's the boy
from the magic door he then bleeds out
beneath the sky of thunder and lightning
end scene now if philosopher thomas
hobbes had adult swim and a decent bong
he might have gotten a real kick out of
this moment
see he thought the heart of why human
society's form is to defend themselves
against a common enemy small
side note here hobb's idea of a state of
nature was violent and chaotic
unlike the peaceful hoovey verse morty
first encountered which more resembled
the state of nature imagined by
philosopher
jean-jacques rousseau that is a
fundamentally innocent one
anyway philosophical caveats aside hobbs
believed that a common and foundational
enemy whether
real or imagined is the main rallying
force that gets us all to work together
and form societies and in rallying
against an enemy
we as members of a society necessarily
sacrifice some of our rights to a
sovereign in order to be better
protected from these external boogeymen
or in this case boogie boys we see the
beginning of a
civilized society on morty's third visit
to the hoovie verse the hoovies have
started cultivating land and even
domesticated a bird
the move to an organized agrarian
lifestyle was of course a very real
stage in the development of human
society
after morty offs the new hoovy patriarch
his sons mobilize an opposition against
their now
sworn enemy constructing what eventually
amounts to a full-blown medieval kingdom
complete with them
creative weapons towers and very devoted
watch guards papa why do we guard the
gate
because one day the dark child shall
return
and we will be ready on morty's next
visit he's
seemingly pummeled to death but this
doesn't end the society's
orientation towards violence against
this mythic adolescent enemy
we finally beat him but let's always
remain vigilant
eventually the king's son speaks out
he's fed up with the morty obsession you
have
wasted our lives our very futures on a
fantasy
clearly people have been subjugated to
build this kingdom in the hopes of
protecting themselves against and we
can't stress this enough
a 14 year old whose only friend is his
grandpa
eventually the hoovies progressed so far
that they become
cyborgs one of whom ponders who would we
be without you morty
are we anything beyond our hatred hobbs
might say
nah but why do we stay stuck in this
pattern especially when war is painful
it involves some very non-delicious
snacks
for answers to that it's worth looking
to notable french disciple of power
lsd enthusiast and one of my personal
bald icons
michelle foucault in his lectures
society must be defended foucault
analyzes 17th century historian
honoree de blanviers who argued that war
isn't really about
individual battles that interrupt
civilized society but rather
is the fundamental schema for organizing
civilized society as such
as foucault explains it is a war that
begins before the battle and continues
after it is over
it is war insofar as it is a way of
waging war a way of preparing for and
organizing war in this way war became a
sort of permanent state that permeates
the entire
social body we see this as the hovies
continue to industrialize in their
perpetual war against morty with the
core of their social order resting on
their relentless need to be prepared to
fight their foe
even when some of the hoovies eventually
do rebel against the prevailing social
order they do so through the only
mechanism they know
more war and violence according to
foucault
the constant state of war informs
everything from religion
to economy to education and its
permeation across society
war becomes an excellent mechanism for
controlling a populace
the sort of subtext of sovereignty it
doesn't benefit those in power to simply
give up the ancestral whovian hatred for
morty and build a peaceful society
doing so would mean giving up control of
its populace who in becoming robotic
emissaries of the war obsessed state
have sacrificed their rights and
autonomy to those in power
none more so than adam whose entire life
has been dedicated to the project
of destroying morty he's the natural
culmination of the hoovey versus
progression from peaceful farmers to
angry peasants to mobilized warriors
of course things go even further when
the hoovies acquire
cybernetic capabilities and literally
become morty murder cyborgs
the project of killing morty then has
literally destroyed organic life
leaving behind only robotic agents of
war and aggression
here foucault's ideas are exaggerated
and literalized hovi society is
literally nothing more than its
preparedness to battle morty
pretty bleak as befits any rigorous
harman effort of storytelling this even
connects to the episode's main plotline
in which
nimbus and rick each define themselves
by their antagonistic relationship their
attempts to find peace between
earth and ocean flounders you get it
flounders
like yeah like the fish in part because
their antagonism is foundational to
their identities much as the hoovey
verse was defined by hatred of morty
do you think he will show you mercy and
if you think this all sounds a little
bit like a certain post 911 warmongering
american national identity
we're certainly not going to say you're
wrong but what do you guys think
are the hooves an excellent example of
the violent fate that inevitably befalls
any society more obsessed with vilifying
its enemies than you know
neighborly good deeds or did we wander
through
a portal of overthinking yet again let
us know in the comments
big thanks to our patrons for your
support hit that subscribe button like
you're unproductively avenging a 100
year old family grudge
and don't forget to ring that bell and
as always thanks for watching
[Music]
later
[Music]
you